president biden didn't just put forward
new anti-gun measures today he also
announced his pick to head the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms
three of my favorite things which
apparently goes by a different name
under the biden administration today
i'm proud to nominate david chipman
to serve as the director of the aft
david knows aft well
and i believe he's the right person at
this moment
for this important agency he knows the
aft well and he's the right person
so who is david chipman well he's a
former atf
special agent but more recently he's
been a shill
for the anti-gun lobby now you've
probably seen him on tv
before calling for insane second
amendment restrictions
for instance three years ago he said
this
about ar-15s what i support
is treating them just like machine guns
the gun would have to be in your name
and there would be a picture and
fingerprints on file if you want to have
a weapon of war
i don't think it's unreasonable at all
that you have to
pass a background check well as someone
who's spent a little time on the
battlefield and owns
multiple ar-15s i can tell you that
statement is a load of well bs
has you ever seen a machine gun fired
one if he has
he should know better but like a typical
tough guy lefty he loves to use the
language of war
but knows nothing about it just as he
knows nothing about why our second
amendment
actually exists but that's not all two
years ago chipman went on pbs
his kind of network to champion controls
on high capacity magazines
when i was on atf swat team my
sidearm had 15 rounds my shotgun
had six i did have an assault rifle
which could hold 30 but i was also
tracking and hunting down the most
dangerous armed americans
which really isn't the job of a civilian
i'm just glad he didn't think there were
magazines with lots of pages in them
so only swat team members have the right
to defend themselves
civilians also face dangerous criminals
especially during the left's
riot if you want while we defund the
police movement
it only makes american families less
safe when you deprive them of the
best tools for self-defense
and finally just over a year ago when
the china virus hit
chipman mocked and scolded americans who
armed themselves how dare they
for the first time they might
think that they're die hard ready to go
but unfortunately they're more like
tiger king and
they're putting themselves and their
families in danger
hide it behind the cans of tuna and beef
jerky that you have stored in a
cabinet and you know only bring that out
if the zombies start to appear oh
you're a fool but he knows better
chipman's nomination is a clear sign
that biden is dead
set and i mean this dead set on grabbing
your guns
and depriving you the ability of to
defend yourself
and your family but of course biden's
claiming his egregious executive
overreach
well it's what our founding fathers
would have wanted
in the very beginning you couldn't own
any weapon you wanted to own
from the very beginning of the second
amendment existed certain people weren't
allowed to have weapons
so the idea is just bizarre to suggest
that some of the things we're
recommending
are contrary to the constitution